فخامه اناقه حفاظ على التقاليد هذا ما كان
عليه الاحتفال الاردني الملكي بزفاف ولي
العهد الامير الحسين بن عبد الله والاميره
رجوى
سمير والاميره كان حديث العالم في يوم
زفافهما وتفاصيل الزفاف جعلتهما بطلي قصه
خياليه بكل معنى الكلمه ساعه خاصه في صباح
العربيه اليوم للحديث عن العرس الملكي
الاردني وكيف عاشه الاردنيون والعرب باجمل
تفاصيله
[موسيقى]
الفرحه مستمره عرس من عالم اخر زواج
بمراسم ملكيه وثقافه اردنيه خالصه عكست
حياه الاردنيين وتفاصيلها الدقيقه بالفعل
يعادل هذا ما كان عليه زفاف ولي العهد
الاردنيه الامير حسين بن عقيلته الاميره
رجوى السيف هذا الزفاف ابهر العالم وحضره
المئات من الشخصيات السياسيه والاعتباريه
من دول عديده شاركت الاردن افراحها الزفاف
الملكي شهد العديد من الفعاليات الفنيه
والفقرات الاحتفاليه الشعبيه والتي ميزت
الفلكلور
والتراث الاردني بشكل كبير اللحظات
المميزه كانت كثيره السعاده الفرح على
وجوه الحاضرين كانت السمل ابرز
لعل اجمل الاشياء التي كانت وشهدناها في
يوم التفاعل الشعبي مع الفرح الملكي
التاريخي حيث اجتمع الاردنيون جميعا كما
راينا تحت شعار نفرح بالحسين
[موسيقى]
سالنا الناس في الاردن ما هي ابرز لحظه في
العرس الملكي عكست هذه التقاليد الاردنيه
[موسيقى]
اليوم نفرح في الحسين
اكثر يعني مشهد كتير حبيته كان من الاميره
سلمى والاميره ايمان وهم يساعدوا زوجه
اخوهم
مشهد حبيته لما جلاله الملك عبد الله سلم
السيف للامير حسين
[موسيقى]
نسي انهم اميرات
وقعت الشنطه كمان هاي كيف قبل الامه تنزل
طالوها فانه اشي كثير حلو صراحه
[موسيقى]
لا مشاهدينا من عمان رئيس مركز التوثيق
الملكي الاردني الدكتور مهند مبيضين اهلا
بك دكتور معنا في صباح العربيه
وهينا عم نشوف حتى يعني قلب الثقافه
الاردنيه وراءك واثار الاردن من ورائك
صباح الخير دكتور شكرا لك صباح الخير لك
صباح الخير لك وايضا صباح الخير استاذ
عادل والمشاهدين حياك الله صباح الفل طيب
دكتور
تاريخ
ي وحتى بقيه العالم ابرز المحطات برايك في
هذا الزفاف مع انه يعني انا كنت بشوف انه
كل محطه في كانت مميزه بامتياز خلال كل
مراسم هذا الفرح الملكي
كما تفضلت الحفل كان غني وثري باظهار
الشخصيه الثقافيه الاردنيه والموروث
الثقافي الاردني بنفس الوقت يعني اعطى
غلاف وخصوصيه ان يكون عرسا لولي عهد من
عائله ملكيه منحدره من الاصول يعرف كل
العرب وتحظى بتقديرهم واحترامهم منذ
اللحظات الاولى الاعلان عن الزفاف ومنذ
التحذيرات الاولى التي قامت بها جلاله
الملكه رانيا العبد الله حفلات الحناء
للسيدات وللرجال حتى ايضا ان ولي العهد
سمع انه في احدى السيدات في احدى القرى
تتمنى انها تحنيه راح زارها وسلم عليها
وجلس معها في قريه في الشمال الاردن في
حرثه لم يترك مكانا للامنيات الا واستطاع
او حاول ان يحققها لمن يريد ان يساهم او
يشارك في حفل زفافي سواء بالتحضيرات او في
المقاصد الاولى او في النهايات التي تمت
بالنسبه لموضوع الحفل وتم خلال اليوم
الاربعاء والخميس في الجمعه هي عمليه
مرتبه منظمه مدروسه بشكل كامل وهناك نظام
واسس في التشريفات الملكيه وكل الدوله
بشكل عام لكن التشريفات لها وضعيه خاصه في
هذا الموضوع هي التي تتدخل وهي التي تحسم
لكن ايضا كان هناك حذف ذلك عمليه اعداد
ومنهج لصناعه محتوى في هذا العرس خاصه ان
المنطقه العربيه والاردن بشكل خاص ايضا
كان يحتاج لمثل هذه البهجه وهذا الفرح بعد
يعني سنوات ليست سهله على المنطقه مرت
علينا خلال دكتور الدكتور دعني اسالك عن
شيء معين اليوم احنا قليل ما نشاهد هذه
الاعراض الملكيه اليوم يعني لا احنا
شاهدنا او عن نفسي على الاقل لم اشاهد
زفاف الملك عبد الله ولا والده الملك
الحسين لكن اليوم هذا التوثيق خاصه حينما
دخلت العروس يعني من ادخل العروس هو اخ
الملك الحسين او الامير الحسين
ايضا الاميرات هنا من كان يعني يرتب ذيل
الفستان اذا جاز التعبير هذا هذا كله
لماذا لم يتم الاستعاظ عنهم بعاملين في في
القصر
الاصرار على ان يكون العرس يعني خلطه
اردنيه متكامله واسريه ايضا والاسره ايضا
اظهرت لانها عائله مثل اي عائله اردنيه
الاب جلاله الملك توقف وقال اهلا وسهلا
فيكم تفضلوا على العشاء مثل اي عرس بصير
في اي قريه او اي مكان من الاماكن الاردن
او في اي بلد عربي ربما الاجابه العادات
بيننا وبين دول الخليج ايضا نفس الشيء
خوات الامين الاميره سلمى والاميره ايمن
تصرف المشكله تصرفك خوات عريس وراء
التواضع الحقيقي
مثل يعني هذه هي بصراحه شيء مش مش جديد
على العائله العشريه في الاردن ونحن دائما
نقول انه شباب احنا ندرك تماما قيمه هذا
التواضع لكنه هو موجود بالاساس ليس فقط في
العرس وليس امام الكاميرا نحن نعيش كل يوم
ونتعامل معه ويوجد في التاريخ ما يوثق
لدينا قصص كثيره كبيره موضوعات مثلا اخو
العريس السمو الام الذي مسك بيد العروس
ايضا استمرار للتقليد ايضا عندما تزوج
الملك عبد الله اللي قدم جلاله الملك
رانيا اخوه فيصل يعني الامور كلها مدروسه
بشكل دقيق ومنهج حفلات الزواج الملك حسين
عندما ايضا تزوج المره الاولى غنى فريد
الاطرش الاميره تزوجها بعدين بنت عمه
وبعدين لما تزوج الاميره منى نفس الشيء
الزهران الى البلد في موقف احمر وسلم على
الناس وهكذا في تواصل وفي تواتر في هذا
الموضوع فكره المضارب المضارب ايضا لما
تزوج الملك عبد الله جاءوا الناس وعمل
الملك حسين الله يرحمه مضارب حتى يعني بعد
العرس اكتشفوا انه بعض الشيوخ العشائر
والقبائل جايبين نقوط حلال وغنم بعدين شو
نعمل فيها بعدين ودوها ايضا للجيش حتى
بيذبحوا فيها ويتردوا فيها فهذا الجانب
مهم استمراريه متواصله في الثقافه اهداء
السير ايضا اذا لاحظت حتى لقطه السيف
عندما يعني وكل اللي زي ما ذكرنا كل
المحطات كانت محطات هذا الزفاف الملكي
مميزه بشكل كبير وجميل لاستمرار هذه يعني
تقاليد والثقافه الاردنيه في كل الاعراس
الملكيه المتعاقبه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
مهند مبيضين رئيس مركز التوثيق الملكي
الاردني الف مبروك يا دكتور لكل الاردن
مبروك
المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات